Richard Sherman got all this attention
he goes on this rant what's your take on
this on this whole yeah I don't care
what any of them talk about the second
the game's over I shut it off that one
was hard because it was right at the end
of the game instantaneous everybody was
just screaming I thought he was gonna
stop crying I didn't know what was
happening he might be that confident but
my gut says I just think he needs a hug
I think somebody did say listen you're
doing a hell of a job out there people
are gonna notice it's hard you're in
Seattle you know maybe we'll get traded
to New York and everything will get
amplified but yeah people are aware yes
a look at your stats yes things are fine
yeah I'm sure he's a nice guy I don't
know how do you feel about this I don't
like how they interview the coaches to
when they go to the half and a half time
yeah as they're running off like I think
they should just be able to stay focused
on the game they shouldn't have to talk
to somebody in like a skate park er like
yeah you know you're down by 14 what are
your thoughts it's like what the what do
you think my thoughts are I'm worried
about my job I'll probably have to sell
my house
it's gonna leave me I need to score more
points than the other half who are you
why am I talking to
you're not even in football yeah you can
play to the high school level no no
probably took journalism yeah get out of
here it's a bunch of nerds interrupting
people who know what they're doing
I don't I don't like when journalists go
into a war area and they put on a helmet
and this stupid best booth award in the
back so you don't think journalists
shouldn't wear helmets and vests either
join the army but get out of it they're
not gonna see anything that they don't
want you to see you know they got a
drone right outside the the camera thing
if the guy does anything that can take
them out yeah
you